grâce à la grève de l'hygiène beaucoup
moins dangereuse que la grève de la faim
de plus en plus de gens peuvent accéder
à la contestation
aujourd'hui nous sommes rendus chez une
des grévistes qui pratique cette
nouvelle méthode de lutte
madame solange picot les beaux tricks
[Musique]
selon ge quand avez vous commencé votre
grève en 1975 janvier très exactement
quand j'ai pris conscience des
événements du sud est asiatique j'ai
voulu protester peuvent vous fait j'ai
cessé de me brosser les dents et à peine
huit mois plus tard vous vous lèverez un
autre combat c'est exact al'annonce de
mise en place de gilles nucléaire en
europe mon sang n'a fait qu'un tour et
j'ai menacé de ne plus me laver les
pieds
cependant les missiles sont construits
et vous mettez votre menace à exécution
ils étaient prévenus
et puis c'est 78
oui en solidarité avec les bébés phoques
je casse ma douce et des commandes
jusqu'à nouvel ordre mais quoi faire
pourtant vous n'êtes pas entendu en 79
les massacres continuent alors vous dire
si c'est votre rêve
et oui je fais murray définitivement ma
salle de bain et brûlé tous mes gants de
toilette et puis soudain une partie de
l'opinion publique vous lâche on vous
reproche d'aller trop loin quand vous
décidez de ne plus vous l'avez les
aisselles et coûté tant qu'il restera
sur terre un seul pays vous m'entendez
bien seul ou ne respectera pas les
droits de l'homme qu'on ne compte pas
sur moi pour me nettoyer pas plus les
aisselles que solange sur l'enjeu vous
irez vraiment jusqu'au bout
je me suis donné toute entière à mes
idées je ne reculerai pas
merci beaucoup
ce pic où vous devez être fier d'être le
mari d'une militante du oui oui ma face
et c'est pas tous les jours facile
vous souffrez de sentir votre femme dans
cet état de la sentir dans cet état
alors oui oh oui beaucoup beaucoup et
puis il ya cette solitude voyez-vous
éprouvante si éprouvante
vous voulez dire que vos amis vous ne
laisse au oui oui surtout depuis qu'elle
a refusé les deux caisses de savon qui
ont envoyé la croix rouge alors là oui
et votre famille ne vous soutient pas
non plus jusqu'ici par téléphone
uniquement par téléphone ça faut les
comprendre
est-ce que vous pensez que les récents
événements et les déclarations du
général san aux accouchements
je vous en supplie taisez vous il n'est
pas encore au courant non justement en
ce moment je suis en train d'écrire au
président des états unis pour qu'ils
règlent au plus vite toutes les
histoires d'amérique centrale
oui la menace est d'entraîner dans la
grève
son beau frère et sa femme qui est une
femme qui alors là non vous écrivez
souvent président des états unis
tous les jours depuis cinq ans tous les
jours ainsi qu'au premier secrétaire
durée cesse d'ailleurs tous les jours et
quelles sont leurs réactions
elles sont embêtés sont très embêtés ça
ils sentent bien qu'il faut qu'il fasse
très attention parce qu'au prochain
troubles mondiaux en fin de mois en tous
les cas on tiendrait pas le coup quand
j'ai projet ça se discute
[Applaudissements]
ils ont libéré les prisonniers
politiques urbaniste ans ils ont subi
par malema
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non pas les poignets c'est pour les
ségrégationnistes
oui super
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]